so it's a new year 2015 right yeah last
time i checked great yeah
so and um paradigm shift you had a new
sort of awakening what prompted that
yeah so this kind of brewed for us last
year i think didn't it
yes and i would say at the in the middle
to the end of
2014 we sat down and realized
we have got to take control of what
we're doing and
go in a completely different direction
instead of
chasing the dream let's make the dream
ourselves and make it a reality
and so that was that was a big parademic
shift
for us yeah because i think like after
obsoleting it was kind of curious like
we had made that completely off the grid
and without any support from sort of
the mainstream system but what happened
and it was an interesting thing because
it got into sundance and suddenly we got
you know these like all these doors sort
of opened and we sort of settled into
this
the conventional pattern you know like
going to meetings and just doing things
like you know
like everything in the conventional sort
of expected way of our industry
which was the opposite of how we had
made obsolete i mean if we'd made tried
to make obsolete that way we never would
have made it
and so you know suddenly we were in that
we settled in and you know i was making
my second film and it was during that
process so that we just were like
you know i had some frustrations making
it and i was like
i just wanted to make something again
like obsolete like and i thought back to
that experience i was like
damn like we really figured something
out with that you know
and we did it kind of innocently you
know
like we didn't you know it wasn't it
wasn't strategic it just like happened
but i went
the way that we did that is that like is
the clue for the future
and i thought i just want to get back to
that like i want to make stuff like
just find a way to like enable ourselves
to
to be empowered to make the films that
we want to make and get them out there
and i realized for for myself and i mean
we talked about this a lot
you know we realized to make that happen
and to sustain it you know
does involve creating more community you
know it's like
and i i talked about this on a blog i'm
like you know definitely for this new
model to exist if you don't want to be
part of the mainstream system so you're
getting like
your money and your power from the
people the powers that already exist and
you have to wait for them to choose you
in a sense to make your movie and
then you have to like jump through the
hoops to make the movie right for them
you know if you're gonna try and do this
in a completely other way where it's
like a little
punk rock like we're gonna do it
ourselves we're gonna make our movie and
then we're gonna sell it
yeah you know then you need to like
engage and we need to like
build community and we need to support
each other you know and for me i had
always been very reticent about being
involved in any social media
i was just like i'm not a social media
person um
and you know suddenly i was like you
know what i'm like i'm changing the
paradigm here you know i'm just like
gonna change a bunch of stuff and try
like a new way
of doing things and i suddenly realized
too we had also been very close about
to some extent how we made obsolete we'd
helped a lot of people
ourselves you know like following that
make their films
but you know just something about i want
to take it to a different level like you
know i want to be really transparent
about what i'm doing
and how i've done it and help other
people i just think like this is one of
the big things that i really
you guys like i want to help other
people make their films you know
and give whatever knowledge i have
truthfully
to them and i just feel there's so many
lies in our industry and that really
disempowers filmmakers
because everything is like kind of inner
shrouds of success
because everyone always wants to make
everything look more successful than it
actually was
you know and so i just want to actually
really really be as honest as i can
we're planning to make a new film uh
this year in
2015. uh we're still working on the
script right now
it's uh it's gonna be micro budget i
think the budget's gonna be
smaller than obsolidia uh where it's
shooting out in the desert it's a cast
of like three
and um you know my intention with that
is 100 to do
like you know just to follow through
this vision like what we're sharing and
what we're teaching like
and make it all transparent you know
like every step of the way here's how
we're doing it
you know yeah um go ahead
what were your hesitations with social
media you know i just grew up in a
different
like you know i feel like i grew up
before it became really the thing
and so my initial usage of facebook for
instance i'm not a digital native
you know i'm definitely a digital
immigrant and
like facebook for instance it seemed
like great for you know connecting with
my family initially because my family
will live overseas but then it started
to get bigger and it was like more
people and i i felt like
i'm a very private person you know and
so that
felt challenging to me and i couldn't
really see
you know it just seemed like oh this
just seems like a big waste of time i've
got so much already things
that i'm doing and i don't i don't
really know what my voice is
on these platforms either and i don't
really
i just don't really get it you know it's
just not my thing and i've talked to a
lot of filmmakers
you know of sort of my age and uh level
experience who feel the same way who are
still not engaging in it or someone is
like it's just not for me
you know and i think obviously um
younger filmmakers are in their 20s it's
totally their language and it's totally
natural to them and it's amazing
and you know i just realized for myself
that that's like that paradigm shift
like
you know always you have to be willing
to adapt you have to be willing to
change you know
and what i've discovered curiously in
the very short time that for instance i
engaged in twitter and he'll tell you
like i love this
i can't believe i didn't do it before
this is so much fun and i've like you
know met all these people and sort of
you know like really i feel like
connected
with um you know like my tribe my people
i'm like oh my god they're here you know
and it's
i absolutely love it and i love the
communication and
i just i think it's absolutely brilliant
and i can't believe i didn't i didn't
get into earlier
you know um so i just feel for me the
paradigm shift is really going
i want to find a way and i think like i
think a lot of filmmakers
are feeling this too i want to find a
way to just like be able to make the
films i want to make
and make enough money for them that i
can keep making them
you know and it's not like nobody's
going to get rich or anything or maybe
you will
maybe you will you know make one one day
that will just knock it out of the park
and you will get rich from it but that's
not the aim the aim is just to like
create a sustainable life as an artist
you know
and i feel like there's a lot of
filmmakers wanting to do that right now
and i feel like
if we support each other you know if we
work together as a community
we can do it yeah you know and that's
really like
where we are right now like that's 2015
to me i'm just like community
you know and it's not just about uh it's
certainly not just about my films it's
really like helping other people to make
their films
you know i'm like working with a couple
people right now
very closely on their projects and i'm
just like i just and i get so much out
of it i'm like this is
amazing you know and i i'm i think
there's just masses of opportunities for
filmmakers right now
but the way it will really work is if we
support one another
you